[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and for the last time
this year we're breaking
[Music]
down the final episode of the first part
of season 2 has just dropped and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the Easter eggs
connections to the comics and everything
that you need to know it was spoke to
co- showrunner Simon rasop about what
happened in this entry and some of the
themes so make sure you stick around for
that please hit the Thumbs Up Button one
last time and without the way huge thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
Invincible okay so predominantly this
episode takes place around issue 26 to
30 though there are other elements that
are part of it those are the main points
that we're going to be covering if
you're interested in the comics now the
midpoint of issue 26 is Nolan recapping
where his journey took him to at the end
of season 1 that's actually where we
begin here the sounds of avalanche by
Nick C we watch him journeying across
the Stars the song was originally
written by lonard Cohen with him basing
it off a poem that he wrote when he was
younger in the comics we get the
conflict really spelled out for us with
omn man discussing how he felt upon
refusing to kill mark even said that
inside he knew Mark was weak and had to
die and that that was the Vite way
having all in then stud that he had two
choices one in which he killed Mark and
Enslaved the Earth and one in which he
didn't in the end he realized he
couldn't do it and and we saw as he fled
into the stars now as we know there are
other Earths where Mark joined up with
his father and they took over the planet
eventually though as we saw with Levi
things didn't always lead to Victory
still though there are those realities
where he came out on top but both
couldn't do something that requir the
death of their loved one as he sits out
on the planets we also get an image that
Rifts on the panel in the comics with
him pitched on a rock looking out at the
stars off is in a monologue in the book
we know what his plan was and he was
actually seeking out of the planet as a
way to make good on his failure Nolan
wanted to find another planet and hoped
that if he enslaved it then the vites
would welcome him back with open arms as
we know they're outlooking for him in
the Galaxy as abandoning your post is
punishable by death now within a week of
leaving Earth we learned he discovered
thraxa but the journey in the show is
far more fleshed out we see him
traveling the cosmos and at one point
even standing on the edge of a black
hole this is model in the same way that
a rendering of one was created for
Christopher Nolan inter Stella using
calculations they created a simulation
for one which is sort to be exactly how
one would look in real life unlike the
comic Nolan actually finds his new home
by saving a doomed vessel rather than
going out specifically as a conqueror it
shows how much he's changed as a person
and this was the man who originally was
willing to let others die because he
viewed them as less than him talking
about this guy thank you didn't think I
was going to make it watch your watch
your back now he ends up going to leave
but he's welcomed as a hero now
technically the people here are what he
should view as being lower than human as
the insect like and have very short
lifespans they only live for roughly 9
months which would seem even more
insignificant to this man who lives for
Millennia they welcome him with open
arms and view him as a hero that helps
out who he can in the comics he saw that
because of their short lifespan they
cycle through leaders at an alarming
rate thus it wasn't long until he was
the oldest person on the planet and thus
he could take control and just run
things from the throne here though they
vaulted things up a lot but also changed
Mark's reaction to how he is with them
in both the pair clench their fists up
and it seems like they're going to duuk
it out Mark makes a move to see if he's
going to Flinch as in the comics he just
goes straight in for the hug in the show
marks way more argumentative and
probably how someone would act in real
life he berates him for killing
thousands and manipulating him to get
there whereas in the source material he
just begs for him to come back both I
think are valid comments on divorce and
how kids act went confronted by their
parents in the aftermath this is
something I spoke about with Simon back
for episode 1 but it spoiled things in
there so I thought I'd leave it out the
video but it will be posted a full
interview on our Clips Channel now Mark
finishes the conversation by telling him
to F off whereas in the comics they then
to the planet it's way more dismissive
with him begging him to come back but
Nolan Coy says that he's made a new home
here Mark takes to the sky determined to
just fly home but his dad calmly talks
him down into returning to the planet
Nolan appeals to his better emotions and
he knows that he'll stay because the
people need his help this better aside
is clearly rubbed off on him too when he
wants to protect the planet as he's
built a life there we then get a scene
where he introduces his wife and and the
P oh God I'm going to be SI now but this
kissing was in the comics too and it's
it's probably one of the most memorable
moments in the entire run it's easily a
metaphor for when you find out one of
your parents has moved on and is with
someone else and to make things more
difficult the per had a kid at this
point mark meets his half brother who
looks his way because of his Vite DNA
that's so strong it actually overpowers
his thxs inside and makes him look more
like what a Vite does now I did weigh up
whether dispo his next bit or not and
that is to just call him by his name in
the comics it's kind of sentimental how
he gets it though so I think it's best
not to do it for now so I'm just going
to refer to him as being Mark's brother
at this point we C to the title sequence
which is covering a swear word instead
of invincible you got to
be St works well but it shows how things
have turned on their heads to the point
that even the title sequence is now out
of whack and X we jump to death and we
can catch her walking barefoot still
broken from that SOS meeting the song
talks about us someone who's had their
relationship fall apart but in the end
would still kill for the person that
left them they talk about being set up
alone on Olympus and longing for that
person to come back to their life Debbie
is very much a broken woman and while
Nolan's off doing his thing she's stuck
in this isolated State I love the way
the things are put together here and we
just see her wandering the streets alone
this of course reflects how Nolan flew
through space and in the end it's a
beautiful marrying of the images and
watch one of the darkest moments in the
season we see she looks out over a
bridge and clearly contemplates whether
it's worth living anymore now this along
with a majority of the stuff from the
show involving her is all brand new
though she has a bit later on that PS
from the comics it is still mainly new
stuff I really love how they've taken
the time to flesh her out here though as
she's really one of the most tragic
characters in the entire show that
didn't get our full focus in the source
material and that moment comes out when
we see her sat in her home drinking
alone and what's almost a completely
wordless page looking through photo
albums and drinking on her own this is a
moment later built upon by the visit
with art either way we have her visiting
Nolan's grave and see how opposite the
description is to what's revealed in the
end it's kind of true that what it says
I suppose H but not with Debbie and Mark
I do love your mother but she's more
like a a pet to me rough no she
basically made up who he was but to be
fair he fooled the entire world that's
what makes the backlash and turmoil
Debbie feel so deating because Nolan
managed to trick everyone on Earth
however she's the one who's still living
with the Betrayal while everyone else is
now getting back to normal now speaking
of getting back to normal we see the
MERS back in their Factory creating a
clone and duplicating their brains the
story here pulls from issues 28 and 29
with a duplication and conclusion
playing out across three pages we see
what happens when one M andos are
original and how this creates a power
and balance at leads to jealousy we had
to make it seamless otherwise one of us
knows he's the Clone and that never ends
well Jan being badly busted up we now
know for definite which one the original
is and there's such a funny panel in the
comic where he he's just bossing him
around and in both the original says
that it's going to be so much better now
back at Debbie we cut to Donald knocking
on her door and he goes on an
introspective look due to his
existential crisis looking at the pile
of rubble he starts to piece things
together and in the end discovers that
he's a robot he does this by slicing
himself open which reminded me a lot of
the scene in Terminator 2 now as always
stuff's been vastly moved about for the
show with these elements happening a
hell of a lot differently firstly the
MERS actually Clon themselves and then
the original died before the next one
was created and they then headed out it
was at this point that they were then
caught by a robot who brought them in to
move across his mind so all that was
happening way later on as was the stuff
with the Rihanna Man and Rick Donald
went into comfort him because he'd been
turned into a Cyborg and Rick was
wondering if he'd ever get a normal life
now at this point Donald opened up to
reveal he was one too and talked about
the wife and family that he'd gone on to
have nobody had known that he was
actually part machine and it helped for
him to basically act as a very
supportive character he he did learn way
before the comic began so him
discovering it here is just giving
Donald more to do anyway across at the
University we see Eve meeting Amber and
William but she's clearly struggling
with what happened last week now the
important thing to pay attention to here
is Amber struggling with Mark being away
I think once we pick up the second part
of the Season you you're going to see
the tall this trip takes is Mark's not
exactly getting home anytime soon so you
have all that to deal with while Mark
has his own issues as well back on track
so we see Mark's angered about being
replaced and how Nolan's priorities and
mind State have changed like the source
material we discover that velites are
forbidden from breeding with inferior
races and how they were cool with humans
but grasshopper girls are too much it's
too much mate they'll be viewed as being
inferior and thus wiped out along with
Nolan's Son Nolan genuinely seems to
repent what he did and he's found
Humanity getting snug with the bugs now
he wants to start training but in both
versions at times cut short in the
comics we had a guy bursting in R he the
vites rain down like gods they do that
in the comics too but it's a lot more
sudden with the members also being
slightly different as well at this point
mark races across the skyline and we see
Mark dashing away with andresa and his
brother and in his arms it's just like
the comics and Nolan took one look at
Andressa and couldn't wait to
Andressa no elsewhere We join Eve at the
Guardians of the globe headquarters we
take a bit of a focus on the shower and
this is of course where she discovered
rlod was cheating on her with duplicate
interestingly this interior is also very
similar to how it's presented in the
comics when Rex blow discovered that
duplicate was cheating on him she can't
go back home and doesn't want to go to
The Treehouse so she ends up lying low
here at this point she over here has
killed Cannon breaking in who you might
recognize from the first episode of
season 1 this was the first person Mark
for after getting his costume and it's
also the first time he used his
superhero name Kell Cannon was a
transformative villain for Mark and now
here he works as this again for Eve now
back on trxa we see Mark arriving at the
secret tunnel these are the caves of
rlan which Andressa is unsure of the
origins of this is likely because of how
short the lifespan of them is and
chances are they probably only got found
three years ago in the comic so we
discover a bit more and learn that traxa
used to endure massive lightning storms
they say this happens once every
generation and thus Ro Clan sort them
out so that people could find shelter
with them just living 9 months it's
probably just part of the seasons but
they see it as being this legendary
thing from the past also Andressa says a
lifespan's about a year but yeah Comics
just just drilled into my brain anyway
at this point she explains how the
civilization works and how they have to
pick things up quickly in order to
advance as a people in the comics it's
explain they Master any task almost
instantly upon doing it which is a
necessity of their lack of time the pair
also have a conversation here that's
akin to the source material with her
very much talking about how she and
Nolan fell in love makes you relate to
her a lot and finally Mark sees that
it's not her fault unfortunately though
it's broken up by big character from the
comics Mark's second vro my test in the
form of Lucan though the other two
members on in the source material here
they brought him across to have these
moments playing out now Lucan was first
introduced here on the comics though I
think we may have seen a younger version
of him in the show before there was a
guy that looked like him with a bit of
hair in the velro might flashback but I
don't think we'll ever get a confirm
whether that's the case or not either
way in the comics lucan's arrival is
what ends issue 27 with us getting a big
Cliffhanger about what would happen next
he actually tells Mark that if he's able
to withstand his assault he'll let him
live and if not then he'll die the vrait
of course have a spart type mind stay
where and there only the strongest
survive thus Mark going Toe to Toe is
the only way to prove his worth with
Lucan being one of the planets most
powerful members it's during this in the
comics and show that he then discovers
Ander and his brother which then leads
into a big fight now they do change
things up as in the source material mock
fleas and it's only when flying through
the air that omn man intervenes here
though Nolan arrives in the caves and
this was done to give us this added line
stay away from my children lukan you
knew the consequences when you had them
just goes to show how Nolan knew what
kind of world he was bringing them into
and how his children would always be in
danger it also allow allows Mark to save
andresa and his brother with it's
getting way more focused on the Nolan V
Lucan fight in the book we never
actually see the disemboweling Raz here
they go all out with it it also changes
things by having andresa go further into
the caves Ras they were out and about
already so they then flew back and
dropped her off just neater really in it
just just more economical having the
fight remain in the caves rather than
them leaving and then going back to drop
her off and then leave again anyway we
see kill Kenan and Eve going Toe to Toe
on the bridge and it's kind of the
staple of lots of superhero showdowns
they did it first in the Spider-Man
films then The Amazing Spider-Man
Fantastic 4 it was in that as well
basically load of them because it
involves Heroes having to fight a threat
but also protect the innocent bystanders
there this is what gets Eve called out
and she has to dive in to try and save
two people again it's playing into her
fear that any good action comes with a
cost and she can't do right for doing
wrong is that a saying also nice detail
having her scuba gear but in the end she
she's just clearly shook now back with
Debbie we see she goes through her old
photos at which point she's then joined
by Art this is kind of playing off the
back of a pot in issue 22 when the pair
go to a b and then drown their sorrows
you have to remember he was pretty much
Nolan's best friend and in the comics
they have a lot of time sharing drinks
and just joking around OD is someone who
also got fooled as well and he too
struggled with the lies that he told him
Debbie starts to realize that Nolan was
hardly there and that due to his life
she almost raised mark single-handedly
She's a reason why mark toi his father
and she's the reason that the world
wasn't enslaved it was her teachings
that caused him to be the way he is
which is a really good message to take
from this all now elsewhere we watched
Donald investigating the truth and see
the surveillance on omn man's house in
episode 7 we watched as he threw that
Soldier out whose spine was twisted
which we get a different angle of In
This Moment Donald also sees his death
playing out as well with a scene in
which he blew everything up it's been an
honor
sir who are you talking to
it's been an honor
sir who are you talking to cut to thorax
and we get a moment ripped right out of
the comics in which they discover the
bodies left in the wake of the vites
that was what closed out issue 28 with
an ex moment picking up in issue 29 we
have Nolan grabbing his son's neck with
him being enraged that he cares about
the traxon mark explained in the comics
that it was normal which then made him
snap and grab Mark's throat here they
flip the order and as Mark explains this
he basically talks about how he should
have felt on earth now at this point the
two other V might show up with the
positioning being ripped right out of
the comics the leader here is thuler
who's a character that comes from the
source material she was actually
inserted into the Montage of beltrum
back in season 1 with her being a big
character that comes from the pages
however she appears way way later in the
run so they bumped her up here to make
the character more impactful early on we
will be meeting more women as part of
the fleet later on but it just goes to
show how tough the women in the the
society are I've always loved the blade
that she has in her hair as well and she
promises to kill mark quickly because of
who his dad is Nolan and Mark managed to
stand their ground but the battle's big
and bloody and completely over the top
Nolan tells his son to stop holding back
and that if he doesn't fight to kill
that it's only going to go one way This
Moment's in the comic 2 with Nolan
holding his son as he tells him to get
ready in the end it pushes Mark to where
he needs to go and showcases that he's a
very powerful Warrior we sort of get a
big montage and it plays out in a big
way taking place across two pages the
art for the battle here is so good with
us getting the characters fighting on
top of a background of snapshots of the
Skirmish in the end the pair come out on
top but Mark refuses to do the tough
choice gets stabbed and then Nolan steps
in but it leaves him open to an attack
by Lucan this is pulled Straight From
the Source material with him even
holding his guts in as he Stomps down on
his back just like that he then
collapses but in the show he says it's
done to explain to the vites to know how
to pick him up it's
[Music]
done and from here we cut across to
debban seesaw with this being pulled out
of issue 26 yeah it's way more
restrained whereas there she slaps him
and he teleports out Debbie says she
doesn't want the money from Nolan's
books and this is because it'll make
them feel like they're indebted to Cecil
captain of the th Mark will work with
him forever and truly be his slave
because he accepts the money now during
this Debbie's packing up Nolan's stuff
including his book that we see the front
cover of if that guy in the front looks
familiar well that's because this is
actually Nolan Nolan wrote about his
life in some of his work and then sold
it on as science fiction stories in the
end she ends up taking out his baseball
Ms which he of course used when playing
catch with Mark I feel like this is her
refusing to let go and maybe thinking
that one day he'll come back seems
sentimental to hold on to this but it's
of course connected to their son and
maybe she's keeping it to play catch
with him but probably going to get you
on blown off if you do that anyway back
on draa we see Mark is in the same sort
of place to where he was at the end of
season 1 man is bloody beaten and out on
his back with his dad once more going
away however at this Pony says my
books read my books Mark now again this
ties into the cover and in the story
outlines lots of info on the vomit these
are things that aren't well known and
thus they can provide Insight on how to
defeat them Debbie puts on his suit and
then heads out with Nolan's boxes but
hey isn't that isn't that where the
books are Deary me now we see the man
with the Invincible gun which is a story
that appears in the comics they had a
bit where Mark went to Art and he read
excerts of the book guessing that art is
going to be the one who picks it up here
and then Mark reads them later on but
we're going to have to see elsewhere we
watch he returning home attempting to
make amends with their family Donald
also confirms the truth and we see the
lives of the characters changing in
really meaningful ways this is all time
yesterday by Zoe Burke binder which
talks about the past and how you long
for for a time before things went bad
cutting back to traxa we hear the voice
of Clancy Brown who's playing the
legendary character known as general
Creek yeah he basically gives Mark
Nolan's Mission and instructs him to
resume taking over Earth in the comics
man gave him 100 years to do it R here
it seems a lot more immediate he says if
Mark doesn't kill a few then he's going
to kill millions and it brings things
full circle from the opening scene on
another Universe now the credit scene
takes us to m in a moment that's ripped
right out the source material this is
the Clone killing the original MOA and
thus neither's really going to know who
the Clone is shows why they don't like
knowing because in the end it just
creates a power and balance that closes
us out with M kneeling over and we end
things with everyone sort of on the
downside no it was it was really really
enjoyed it and again just with the whole
divorce metaphor seeing omn man move
onto his new life and then Mark's kind
of got to accept that and he's got a a
new brother and stuff yeah it just made
me appreciate the The Source material so
much more and um uh I really really
enjoy those those four episodes I got to
see so thanks so much oh thank you no
thank you like we appreciate I
appreciate the time you spend watching
the show and talking about it because
that helps us get an audience and helps
us make get to make more of the show
which is really all we want to do so
yeah yeah no really really good
genuinely thank you yeah and thanks for
speaking to me as well no I appreciate
it yeah really nice to meet you Paul
hopefully we'll talk to you again maybe
for the back half of season two yeah no
I'm down 100% yeah thanks a lot so
obious see huge thank you to Simon for
taking the time to talk to me about the
show and huge thank you to you guys for
checking out these videos I really
appreciate it I really do thank you guys
so much and I also want to do a season
two part two predictions video very soon
as well so make sure you stay stuck on
the channel for that too again I will be
dropping the interview in full on our
Clips Channel as well and if we get the
opportunity next time I'd love to see if
you guys have any questions that you
want me to ask please tag it with her
name Simon and then I can just search
the comments really easily and get that
brought up please drop a like on the
video as well and if you want to support
the channel as a member of the spoiler
side Squad then please click the join
button you get early access to videos
every week and it goes such a long way
to helping us out going to get some
heavy spoilers merch we've also got our
t-shirt line located below the video
that will let you pick up all kinds of
tops like our spoiler man one Theory
time one house of dragon stuff Marvel
teas and a lot more you drop new designs
on there all the time too so definitely
keep an eye out and thank you for
supporting us if you want some else to
watch we've got a video on screen right
now so definitely head over there right
after this by the way huge thank you for
sting through the video I've been Paul
I'll see you next time you take care
peace